bienvenue à la notice notre tour
d'horizon des jantes et du monde sportif
que paul mekbel je ne sais pas si vous
le connaissez mais pas le mec bête et le
premier millionnaire du disc golf après
avoir signé un contrat de 10 millions
pour dix ans le disc golf c'est
exactement ce que vous pensez que c'est
soit de jour golf avec un frisbee on le
dit super belles images à vous montrer
un million par année pour lancer un
moule à tarte
quand même pas peur à des trucs sur le
disc golf c'est quand on y pense on
trouve ça absurde comme spa et si le
disc golf c'était le sport comme numéro
1 des tad en amérique du nord qu'on
arrive avec un sport qui s'appelle le
golf où est ce qu'on tape stream petit
bal avec des bâtons pour faire comme
n'importe quoi pas besoin de tenir le
match des étoiles de la nba
le concours de dunks est déjà terminé et
ce n'est pas la jeune sensation antoni
and whites qui veulent l'emporter même
si donne quand même sur tout ce qui
bouge
c'est plutôt world un des meilleurs
patineurs extrême monde
[Musique]
oui je voudrais quand même pas qui donne
sur carey price
quand même plus spectaculaire que le
disc golf certains souhaitent que la
silhouette de kobe bryant soit le
nouveau logo de la nba
mais moi c'est lui que je le vois et on
n'a pas encore chanté je tâte semaine
puis oui oui oui oui voila je sais pas
c'est quoi une femme a été arrêtée parce
qu'on la soupçonne d'avoir contrefait
d'écart pee wee d'alexis la fronière et
de les avoir vendues 100 dollars sur
ebay
alors que tout le monde le sait ça
n'existe pas des cartes prix d'alexis la
fronière gens n'ont pas fait en 2013
c'est un piège mais ça c'est des vrais
car depuis deux mois
ça vaut sûrement cher sur les ventes
autres je peux acheter un big bang jobs
penses tu que je parle jamais de mes 15
hockey vous savez ce qu'ils vous chers
pour nous votre look
merci gala une semaine après son
congédiement
on a décidé de faire de claude julien
notre premier intronisé au temple de la
renommée de la nautique claude on sait
pas comment te remercier pour toutes les
perles que tu nous a servi un point
presse
pendant ses cinq années à la barre du
canadien des plus anodines on fait
d'autres chaussures au plus coquines
joue des matches où ado au plus une
attente le timbre claude tu étais pas
jean perron n'était pas loin de mettre
en cause
avec en prime tous les jours nous aussi
on en aurait laissé échapper quelques il
y avait des symptômes de flux claude on
t'aime tu vas nous manquer on avait
encore de beaux moments à vivre ensemble
et marc boivin en a décidé autrement
cette dimension marque oui oui ou
d'émotion oui peut-être que devenir une
chambre va devenir mon nouveau préféré
fuir peau des yeux
pour moi les choses sont effectuées tant
que tels qu'on les met sur la table
c'est pour nous merci tout le monde
avoir été là si vous avez aimé
n'oubliez pas partager la vidéo je
réponds à tous les commentaires
personnellement elle épingle ce pas ses
mots